واحدة من المفضلة لدينا هي Casey التي
لا تعد غريبة عن الأخبار العاجلة ولكن
هذا الخبر فاجأها تمامًا عندما
كانت في المنزل عندما قررت ابنتها
دخول العالم بسرعة كبيرة بعد
13 دقيقة فقط من المخاض ولم يكن
لديهم حتى الوقت للاتصال بالرقم 9  -1-1
تدخل زوجها وساعد في ولادة
طفلهما الثاني
هناك على أرضية الحمام
بمنزلهما، طفل جميل اسمه جميل
greyhunt ريفيرا، أبلغت أمي أنها
تتمتع بصحة جيدة وتبلغ وزنها ثمانية أرطال وأربع أوقيات وهي
معنا عبر الهاتف
كيف حالك؟  أعلم أنني قمت بتحميل
سؤال محمل، انتظر، لا يمكنك الذهاب،
لا يمكنك الذهاب إلى الشعر والمكياج
عندما رأيت هذا في، أستطيع عندما رأيت
قصتك على Instagram في
مقال مجلة People عنك، اعتقدت
أنك أكثر من ذلك  بطلنا الآن عما كنت عليه
من قبل، أنتم
لطيفون جدًا يا رفاق وأشكركم
كثيرًا على استضافتكم لي، نعم أعني أنك
قلت إنني لست غريبًا على الأخبار العاجلة،
كان هذا أنا بالتأكيد غريبًا على
هذا جيدًا، كيف حالك يا كيسي  اه،
كلانا يعمل بشكل جيد جدًا،
بصراحة، كما تعلم، لدي جميع
النساء اللاتي أنجبن أطفالًا،
في الواقع، حياة مدتها 13 دقيقة رائعة جدًا،
ما رأيك في ذلك،
وبصراحة، إنها قصة رائعة
لأنه لا يوجد شيء  حدث شيء سيء وقد حظينا
بعناية كبيرة حقًا من
حريق DC وEMS اه الأشخاص الذين حضروا بمجرد أن
تمكنا من الاتصال بهم في غضون 10
دقائق تقريبًا
وتحدثوا إلينا أيضًا حول نوع
ما يجب فعله اه لأنك تعلم أن
غرائزك تتطلب  انتهى ولكن
فجأة كان هناك طفل وبدأت أنا
وزوجي ننظر إلى بعضنا
البعض ونفكر في ما يجب أن نفعله الآن،
ثم الحمد لله، التقط عامل الهاتف
وساعدنا في شرح
ما يجب فعله بالضبط للحفاظ على سلامتها  ونحن
ممتنون لأن كل شيء سار على ما هو عليه